you posted this picture speaking of kids
when you were a kid and and you you
captioned it well well I think what your
caption was this is you with a girl fan
when you were a kid yes and you you had
a funny caption for it which was I think
scaring fans yeah she was horrified yeah
that was you trying to make a young fan
happy yeah did she ask me it doesn't
look like that the story she didn't we
talked to her what she said she said
that you approached we found this woman
remember she said that you approached
her and you whispered in the ear I'm
gonna be naked all through college and
that's her reacting to it but that it's
really hard because I imagine I'm having
such a great time in that photograph
yeah and she is not and I feel like
that's kind of how it is now all the
time with everybody like I'm loving it
yeah aren't you loving it yeah horrified
yeah yeah like that could be my wife
that could be anyone I know in that
photo right true sociopaths you don't
pick up on the social cues don't read a
Q at all yeah you might but I'm having a
good time yeah sure sure
you'll kill and kill again
wait what just go with it man yes and
I'm trying to get as much bad stuff out
of you as possible because we want to
put this together and like this is
evidence this is evidence yeah okay this
airs you lose your driver's license
you